[Music]
how you doing I'm good man I'm all right
I'll show you girls a little bit cause
it's been like two hours now sleeping in
the car
oh really I just woke up and I'm out yes
or it's good I know that feeling when
you wake up from that nap it's like I uh
honestly is like what it's like coming
into this is that feeling you say man I
don't stand it see these people are
going nuts for you I mean have you
gotten used to a fanfare yet they're
shutting I'm actually hired all of them
just for the you know just for the
energy of it
ask them out after before yeah I just go
for a little variety thumbs all come
down they all got star Niall counts in
their head so virtuoso has a nice ring
to it don't you think I like that man
who really do sophisticated how does it
feel to be included in this group it's
an amazing list it's amazing this I
think it's an incredible time I think to
be recognized for any type of
achievement this early on in my career
for me is the source of endless
motivation and also looking by my side
looking at my peers
ya know Jay obliged on a canoe ye old
great people that we have I think it's I
think it's nice and to be recognized for
Detroit to like amazing amazin working
there I mean what does this moment mean
to you know it means a lot I mean
Detroit is a movie that was very very
important it was hard to make but same
time something that I just am very very
happy if I'm very appreciative oh yeah
obviously between Star Wars and Detroit
and all the amazing work you're doing
you've been rubbing elbows with a lot of
Hollywood elite who's the most famous
person in your phone these days oh my
phone
even if I had some ladder any you know
that nine I know that I'm George George
George asked my cause man I'm trying
trying to get on the Brian Johnson Star
Wars trilogy Bing so what's next for you
what are you working on sleep we're
gonna sleep trying to get trying to get
a full seven hours in I'm gonna live
some life I'm I'm looking my best life
is that's the best way to do it master
I'm I'm just relaxing see what happens I
know you said you bought your parents a
house what's the biggest personal Spurs
you just spent on he's got to him I got
dealt with there's first notes for yeah
that's on every day
you